a happy accident would be the best
way to describe my initial identity with
the wwe universe which is weird because
if i didn't speak up and didn't have the
courage to capitalize on that
opportunity i certainly wouldn't be
sitting here in this wonderful
uniform today
a bunch of my peers were
freestyling on the back of an overseas
tour bus and i usually never joined that
peer group but decided to join in
everybody was impressed including some
decision makers at the front of the bus
one being the uh daughter of vince
mcmahon stephanie mcmahon
she asked if i wanted to play that
persona on tv um and i was about to be
fired so
as a last chance i said sure i'ma win
this i'm gonna make my impression show
vinnie mac that i got ruthless
aggression didn't just rhyme i tried to
embrace as much hip-hop culture as i
possibly could and that kind of started
this whole thing
could we please have a week where you
don't come out here and choke
you may be gi joe this summer right now
you're a gi joke wwe version of john
cena has changed tremendously over the
years and for the last
decade i would say has been a character
with a cornerstone value system of
virtue and a lot of times audiences now
want to
get behind a character who is flawed
like peacemaker who isn't completely um
steadfast in his value system and
doesn't completely operate for you know
hustle loyalty and respect and and the
foundation of pure virtue people want
more depth in a character arc you know
in the wwe we are just playing a role
but i kind of do this for all of the
roles whether it be uh peacemaker or
john cena or whatever i have to try to
look within myself and take moments for
my actual life and
see how i felt and try to put that into
a character i'm not exactly somebody who
kicks in your front door and rips
through your house and jean shorts and a
t-shirt ready to throw my hat at your
parents
and ask you to a last man standing match
but i know what it means to be excited
and if i need to conjure up an emotion
of let's say sadness i
look back on my life and you know
remember when i was sad and
hopefully find some sort of emotion i
can grasp onto and then put it into well
why would my reflection of this person
think they're sad these people are not
jimmies they are the greatest fans in
the world
and i have no idea whatsoever why you
feel the way you do but if it's because
of me and you want a match
i'll tell you the same thing
that i told you last week
i got no problem knocking some sense
back into you
it takes a certain type of individual to
go out there
and play your hit song
every night
for two decades there are decisions i
can make
but i don't make okay now john cena's
gonna be a bad guy i don't make that
choice then i can be like okay i'm never
gonna be a bad guy
how can i nuance a virtuous character
would it have been great
to be able to mess with the flaws of wwe
john cena oh my goodness i think there's
another 10 years worth of story in there
but it's not my choice
i don't i don't run the company april
1st
when the millions see john cena versus
the rock
john cena is going to be eyeing up
dwayne johnson
[Music]
[Applause]
and i don't like dwayne johnson as far
as dwayne johnson's trajectory is
concerned he's broke down so many
stereotypes shattered so many barriers
he allowed the outside public to be like
yeah these wwe guys they may be onto
something none of those opportunities
happen without him by doing what he's
done with class and professionalism
has given opportunity to folks like me
where people are like yeah okay well
i'll i'll take a chance on john i don't
think dwayne understands the impact he's
had on an entire industry of people he
gave me some great advice uh when i got
the audition for a train wreck the
audition process is scary for me like it
is for most people and
it is a business of failure you know you
got to be used to telling you got to be
used to getting told you're not the
right fit and uh i really wanted this
one and
deadpan dwayne was like just be yourself
man they called you in for a reason
just just be who you are
and
and i was
[Music]
the superhero universe the dc universe
it has that universal appeal very much
like wwe people around the world just
get it certainly the nature of the comic
books you don't really have to read the
caption of what's going on you can
follow a comic
and kind of get the story picture by
picture so it transcends language and
it's fascinating these people have
magical mystical powers
through
whatever circumstance gave them those
powers great narratives there and you
develop a cast of characters
the world likes this stuff and me trying
to become a better performer on screen
these are positions you want to be in if
you could get invited into a superhero
universe people are going to see your
work that's the end goal for every
performer you want to be seen and you
want to give it your best shot you want
to be appreciated
[Music]
i pretty much tried every comic book
there was and then somehow found my way
into a band of misfits called the
suicide squad and it wasn't because i
was top of the list either if you talk
to james gunn he had a lot of trouble
casting peacemakers a lot of names
before me for some reason he got to my
name in the phone book and said okay is
he available
and i was and i flew up to atlanta to
talk to him it was very much like the
creative head of wwe when they heard
something that they were like yo would
you want to do that on tv yes i would
nothing like a bloodbath to start the
day they call you peacemaker i cherish
peace with all my heart i don't care how
many men women and children i need to
kill to get it in doing my research
james told me don't read the comic books
read the script this is a comic book
persona that has a bunch of existences
out there from from different people
putting out comics about peacemakers so
i'm just gonna make my own thing
peacemaker
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no i saw a peacemaker especially with
this outfit so i began to take cues from
like george patton who was always the
most vibrant looking general in a photo
and why would you wear a vibrant uniform
uh to lurk in the shadows so to speak
then i started taking personality traits
of like macarthur sort of first on the
battlefield and then trying to harness
that attitude of like a proud soldier
who if he's gonna have a team behind him
he is gonna be the one to tough love
motivate that team and i really
gravitated towards lee army's role in
full metal jacket so i wanted to be that
sort of persona and it fit the words
because
the army rattled off a litany of curses
that would make
anybody proud in that movie and he just
he said it with such conviction in such
direction that it made sense so a couple
takes like that and then finally james
is like no wait this isn't what
peacemaker is he's a douchey captain
america and that was it is a wrap i wish
he told me that months ago and idris and
i just riffed and
everybody was like what the [ __ ]
happened like where did all the where
did all this come from but this whole
beach was completely covered in dicks
and somebody said i'd eat every dick
until the beach was clean for liberty i
would say no problem why would someone
put penises all over the beach that's
why mad men do what they do one our
perceptions can be different and i'm
very fortunate to have the trust and
faith in james when he said that i
didn't be like no he's not
i view peacemakers this so he's this
james is the director
he's the one moving the chess pieces and
he tells me okay your chess piece is
this
got it okay
the marine was a wonderful experience
and it's one i'll never forget because
you can't have a journey without the
first step and the first step is always
the boldest they say timing is
everything and i i was not ready for the
opportunity i was given you know i
always spoke about how i was courageous
enough to step up when
i was asked to embrace hip-hop culture
on wwe programming well this was
a decision made to open a studio and to
try to
diversify the abilities of wwe
superstars the wwe has a tremendous
talent and it's not just
physical talent
i believe their performers just have a
an act and
to no audience their improvisational
skills are second to none they possess
so much more than just physical gifts
and vince mcmahon
agreed with this philosophy opened a
studio and figured if he could make
wwe superstars also
movie stars it would be broader reach
the movies would obviously generate
profit but furthermore we could get
more people to come to the wwe shows so
me
being just enamored with the wwe and it
was my life's passion at the time
i said no problem this was originally a
role that was written for steve austin
and two weeks before shooting
steve backed out for whatever reason
that's that's a conversation with him
but vince said hey i gotta send you to
australia it's okay what am i doing he
said well you're gonna be in a movie
okay when i gotta send you in ten days
but i pretty much left us a small
meeting in his office and packed my bags
and went to to be in the movies which i
knew nothing about so i'm a young man in
his mid-20s i love the life i'm i'm
leading i'm riding the lightning bolt of
live audience every night champion at
the time as a former athlete i get to be
physical all the time i have what i
believe is a good work life balance and
then i get thrown into
um cinematic creativity which is very
patient
it is
a very slow process
and i
just wasn't ready for it i've seen him
kill three people
my wife will not be number four
i can't give you permission to pursue
i'm not asking for it i'm actually very
very proud of the movie you know robert
patrick who i got to work with on
peacemaker uh he plays auggie smith my
dad it was great what a full circle
moment that was to see him again he did
a tremendous job for us on the marine
and and the movie did well people talk
to me about it to this day so it's great
that you know you do something that
people remember and maybe it affects
their life which is really cool but my
mind was elsewhere
at the age and the time in my life i
wanted to be in the ring and i looked
around and i always figured if
if i'm gonna do action
why am i doing it here
why don't i do it in front of 15 000
people because it's so much cooler to do
it then and i only have to do it once
and there is no wrong and it's live at
the time i didn't realize what i was
doing i never realized i was becoming a
more seasoned professional i never
realized the nuggets of wisdom i would
take from my peers i never realized what
the value of that opportunity was and i
just that's i chalked that one up to
being uh
young and ambitious just uh not too wise
[Music]
[Music]
the audition ended up being we read the
script a few times and it's me amy
schumer and judd apatow we read the
script and jeb was like yeah just
put the script down just riff
and
amy was so inviting and judd was so
great
so we could just talk
and they're all very funny so it ended
up being funny oh i am about that right
now no no i will get my crazy up in here
you like movies we'll make a movie oh
god we'll make mama say knock you out
starring my fist and your [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i'm so lucky that people
uh
will smile and chuckle from timing or
something i do on camera
but i think the most important thing is
surround yourself with really funny
people judd and amy assembled a crew
of all-star comedians
and you just
give them an environment to feel
comfortable and do their job
and just be as present as you can and
and have as much fun as you can and
don't be afraid to fail you got to be
like a goldfish in wwe because you got a
show the next night
if you perform poorly
you can you can come back and say that
sucked
okay it sucked because of why and then
you go out there and and do your best to
do it the next night stand up is very
similar so maybe that's why
workshopping and improving the material
i had a little bit more courage amy judd
they created an environment that it was
okay to bomb
because you could tell 80 bad jokes all
they need is one that makes them chuckle
and that's the one the audience is going
to see
and they created an environment for me
to miss and fail
and learn
[Music]
being able to be invited into the fast
franchise it was awesome
it was awesome i grew up on these movies
i i love car culture i love the fact
that this movie was just a
nobody saw it coming and it took the
world by storm i love how the franchise
has evolved into this like super almost
weird
superhero without cape spy movie
underground crime scene but good guy big
caper fight evil save the world type of
stuff
it's one of those franchises that truly
listens to their audience when their
audience says they want something even
when they joke what are they gonna do go
to space
justin lin's like you're damn right
we're going to space in a pontiac fiero
it's had enough installments now where
the stakes are still serious the
characters are still well developed but
in the same movie you get winks to the
camera and i really i really love the
franchise and cast and crew man they're
just they're a family you walk on set
these people have been doing movies
together for 20 years
20 years i've never seen anything like
that except the wwe locker but had a
great time this is a legacy project for
these people there's very few franchises
that get to the ninth installment
and can still say they're kicking ass
these are people that made me better
performers
so anytime you can make a leap from one
level of skill to the next level
it's you don't nobody does it by
themselves no one regardless everybody
has help in anything we do along the way
and these are vin and justin especially
are two people instrumental in helping
me get to the next level i'm so lucky to
be able to say i was a part of the
franchise
ron has a back story that is
pretty intense and has a set of skills
that are pretty admirable but it's not
what defines him
you know it's a guy who's reached a
point in his life
uh where he realizes and probably
because of his past he realizes that
life is the most important thing the
living of the life so you take brave and
courageous chances and you enjoy the
moment and
i don't know he just he has this level
of
wisdom about him and it's probably from
being such a worldly
individual or maybe you know riding that
razor's edge of
existence and non-existence and it's
just cool to see a guy who
doesn't care about the stresses
that all of us build a construct under
and it was wild to just be like
yeah man what that like whatever
it was just so cool to do that but he
wasn't totally uh enlightened
and that was another cool twist about
ron like he seems like he's enlightened
but he's not he still has depth he still
has places to grow he still has flaw
especially with with rel and like with
meredith certainly being like a soul
mate for ron but kind of the polar
opposite the differences were just so
great and rel is so
fast and high strung and like animated
and fun
uh and ron is just like nah man we got
this you know they say money buys you
freedom
but how can you really be free if you
think about making money all the time
well i guess it's your welfare checks
i've been paying
possibly
possibly marcus you know start with clay
writing a great script with a bunch of
jokes and you get a cast full of funny
people
and you let them be funny and you just
kind of
kind of be present
[Music]
travis knight took a bold chance on me
it wasn't like i'm going to bring you on
to this role to tell jokes
he was like you you would be a great
agent burns and if you watch all those
coming-of-age films the bad guy
is kinda jokey serious but jokey whether
it be a principal or a parent they have
that authoritative stance but then they
kind of wink at the camera a little bit
there's a door in my way once again
travis was
really great on being like
do you want to just take a take my
answer is always yes and there would be
points travis is like we don't have time
we don't we're we're moving on but when
he would when he would give me a take to
see this tough guy dressed up in
tactical gear talking about stuff you'd
never think of it just lightened the
mood and i think then he was like okay
we should
he should be the guy to
let everybody know that they're called
decepticons and we should hit that on
the head and he's the right guy to do it
and this is the right setting they
literally call themselves decepticons
that doesn't set off any red flags
enough i guess that that was his ability
to pick up on that and and
give me a little leeway we talked about
me
essentially taking the the role in the
marine for granted that's exactly what i
did i wanted to be somewhere else my
philosophy has changed probably since
2012
where everything that's put in front of
me everything that i'm blessed or
grateful enough to receive i always
appreciate it
and i try to do the best i can